[Music]
all right
it is already that time of the year we
really didn't miss a beat huh
we got new samsung stuff so samsung just
revealed the galaxy s21
and s21 plus and i've got your first
hands-on and some impressions of them
right here
i also just dropped a separate video on
the big dog the galaxy s21
ultra definitely check that out if
you're interested it's the flagship
of their flagships and that video will
be the first link below the like button
but for these two s21 and s21 plus here
we have some very interesting new
numbers new specs
and new prices now there are two new
phones i'm talking about here like i
said
so i figure i might as well talk about
the differences between them usually
it's basically two different phones that
are just different sizes and that's it
this time it's two different phones that
are different sizes
and also different materials so the
smaller s21 comes in at 6.2 inches
while the s21 plus comes in at 6.7 which
is almost the same size as the ultra
and they look and feel pretty close in
size but individually like once you hold
them
you can really tell a difference and
that also of course with the size
difference means
the space inside is different so that's
a different battery 4 000 milliamp hours
on the s21 4800 on the s21 plus
that's pretty impressive and then yes
materials
so the s21 plus has a matte finish over
glass
and the s21 has a matte finish
over polycarbonate aka plastic and so
those two things
are all that account for the difference
in price but it is a 200 difference in
price now
the s21 starts at 7.99 this year
and so the s21 plus starts at 9.99 now
this plastic versus glass thing i
i found it a little bit strange at first
that they would separate it like that i
figured they'd either make both plastic
or both glass
but i guess because they are coming down
in price to 7.99
with the galaxy s21 i can let it slide
plus
plastic like i've said before it has a
weird reputation
it's not actually that bad it just seems
cheap
in more expensive phones but it's less
likely to shatter you can mess with
colors more and ultimately they actually
look
very similar you can just tell the s21
is a little bit lighter
in your hand so this is definitely
something i'll dig into more in the full
review
but yeah everything else here about
these is the
same and pretty new mainly centered
around this new
contour cut design where the camera cut
out as you can see
is all the way up in this ridge platform
thing
in the corner like i said in the ultra
video i kind of like it not gonna lie
i think it looks pretty futuristic but
it definitely stands out the most with
this purple color here
where the camera cutout is gold and then
that gold
wraps all the way around the sides and
the rails of the phone so it's kind of
like a two-piece suit
it's looking kind of like a superhero
costume or something i don't know i wish
there were more versions of color combos
that you could choose from
maybe red and black would have been cool
too maybe
black and white black and yellow
but either way it's a unique look for
sure i'll give them that it doesn't
really resemble anything else i've seen
and i'm into that there's no copying but
on the inside we're going to start to
see a lot of phones
kind of like this one so it's the
snapdragon 888 chip in this region
or it'll be the new five nanometer
exynos chip in other regions and i
definitely want to see if there are any
big differences between them
with this generation but they are
promising 20 to 35 percent faster
performance on cpu and graphics
respectively
there is eight gigs of ram in each like
i said and either 128 or 256 gigs of
storage
this time not expandable now that is a
bummer not just because you are now
limited to 256 gigs of storage
but it's also another removed feature
from last year
technically we had expandable storage in
a micro sd card slot
now it's gone we had glass now it's
plastic the triple camera situation
on the back is pretty standard they
share the same 12 megapixel primary
camera
12 megapixel ultra wide and 64 megapixel
3x telephoto camera that will zoom all
the way into 30x space zoom if you want
not quite the 100x of the ultra but it
does appear to be
much more stable than before and samsung
says it'll focus faster and then the
displays up front
got an interesting update this year
i'm not going to call them upgrade
because again they did technically lose
another feature so this year the
displays
are now adaptive refresh rates so they
will refresh between 48 hertz and 120
hertz
depending on what's on the screen and
that should save you some battery
instead of just being locked at 120 most
of the time
but also the displays are now 1080p
so they used to be 1440p for a couple
years in a row of samsung flagships
now they're 1080p now i know they
dropped the price but now you're talking
plastic you're talking no expandable
storage
you're talking 1080p instead of 1440p
and again it's not that big of a deal
because a lot of people
like me were using their phones at 120
hertz in 1080p
already anyway so it's in theory not
something we should
notice or care that much about it's
already around 400 dpi
for that resolution on that size of the
screen anyway but
it's just a little thing you don't like
getting less than last year
so it's technically an update but i'm
not going to call that an upgrade until
i test it more then the rest of the
changes
are pretty minor but all pretty positive
at least in my opinion so there's a 1.77
times larger
and hopefully also faster fingerprint
reader underneath the glass
there's a couple new software features
built into the camera like a more
advanced director's mode for video
and the recording audio from multiple
sources and things like that
that's all good stuff but yeah it's
really mainly just a spec bump
in a new design with a couple tweaks
that allow them to lower the price down
to 7.99 and i do like that lowered price
i think that is a good move
but it's just gonna depend on how you
feel about the stuff they cut out but
now you pretty much know everything you
need to know
about the newly announced galaxy s21s
clearly the ultra has a lot more going
on
so again if you haven't seen that video
it's also live
check it out but let me know what you
think is this the change you want to see
and does that lower starting price make
you happy
and maybe there's a fan edition later
this year we'll see either way
thanks for watching i'll catch you guys
in the next one peace